bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france
ce qui se joue actuellement au brésil
ces tensions entre les réseaux sociaux
et la justice brésilienne sont aussi des
tensions entre la cour suprême est
d'ailleurs wolson araud qu'est ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui au brésil à ce niveau
aujourd'hui se joue au brésil deux
choses la première c'est la démocratie
brésilienne puisque la cour suprême
aujourd'hui elle n'obéit plus à l'état
de droit est là elle n'avait pas le
droit de bloquer les comptes de
personnel brésilienne elle n'avait pas
le droit de faire ce qu'elle appelle la
l'instruction des faits que nous parce
qu'elle n'est pas le droit de s'auto
saisir et c'est pourtant autosaisie au
mépris des lois brésiliennes
c'est la première chose c'est ado droit
brésilien ait la démocratie la deuxième
chose qui se joue au brésil c'est la
gouvernance c est ce que ce pays
ingouvernable et on voit bien que
monsieur molson arolla on lui enlever
tous les pouvoirs ou presque tous les
pouvoirs et à travers via un instrument
cette cour suprême qui au lieu de
stabiliser le pays et l'aide à le rendre
ingouvernable
ce n'est pas une très bonne nouvelle
pour le pour les brésiliens la cour
suprême qui a pris cette décision de
bloquer donc les comptes facebook et
twitter de proches du président
brésilien dans le cadre d'une enquête
sur une campagne de désinformation qui
toucherait justement l'institution
ouais enfin comme on dit chez nous quand
on veut noyer son chien on dit qu'il a
la rage
hélas au brésil
dans l'époque où nous vivons quand on
veut se débarrasser de quelqu'un on dit
qu'ils propagent des technos au fait le
pour l'instant la cour suprême
brésilienne malgré des mois des mois
d'enquêté n'a pas été capable de révéler
des preuves incriminant ces personnes
dont elle a coupé les comptes et
certaines ont même été en suivi des
perquisitions illégales en nous on veut
des preuves à yaya jeunes en fin je
monsieur besson a rossé amis ne sont pas
au dessus des lois mais ils sont pas non
plus en dessous des lois et c'est
dommage que la cour suprême qui devait
être la garante de état de droit au
brésil ce produit pratique ces choses à
on s'attendait à un coup d'état de la
part de la droite brésilienne sais ce
que c'est de ce que vous avez appris à
craindre
elle a en fait nous avons une grave
atteinte à la démocratie provenant de
ceux qui sont censés la défendre depuis
depuis son coeur justement facebook qui
dénonce une décision extrémistes et
promet de faire appel
quelles sont ses chances d'être entendu
c'est une question compliquée puisque le
brésil est un pays souverain et qui est
très susceptible sur sa souveraineté
donc là
les ministres comme on dit de la cour
suprême brésilien je les vois mal obéir
enfin entendre les arguments de facebook
qui sont censés parce que facebook qui
dit que la loi brésilienne n'est pas
extra territoriale or les ministres la
cour suprême brésilien sont allés
chercher les comptes facebook aux états
unis donc c'est demain ce sera le
gouvernement américain qui va trouverez
votre compte à vous en france sur
facebook
donc c'est une jurisprudence très grave
mais ça très sincèrement c'est
extrêmement incertain les juges
brésiliens et en doute ses juges la
étant doté d'un grand ego centrisme et
d'un d'une certaine vanité peut-être
qu'ils voudront faire rentrer dans
l'histoire par la petite porte et
embêter facebook juste pour entrer dans
les livres d'histoire je parlais de ce
bras de fer qui se joue entre jagger
molson arrow et la cour suprême que
pourrait que pourrait reprocher
justement le président brésilien aux
juges de la cour suprême et à
l'institution elle même
à
il faut savoir que l'institution est
très discréditée au brésil auprès des
brésiliens de la rue puisque elle est
quand même au sommet d'une pyramide
judiciaire qui fonctionne très mal
le brésil étant rêve recordman du monde
des homicides y en a plus qu en syrie en
l'an dernier 74 milles homicide en série
au brésil donc c'est plus qu'en syrie et
la cour suprême du brésil il est au
dessus de ce système judiciaire qui ne
qui permet cela ensuite elle a un retard
énorme dans le jugement de plusieurs
procès
je crois qu'elle a cent mille cas de
retard donc à une file d'attenté normes
donc déjà les brésiliens ils ont ils
sont et son combat contre cette cour
maintenant ball sonar ou lui de façon il
a la langue coupée puisque il est
détesté mondialement on a tissé sa
légende noire a raison il n'est pas très
adroit il faut dire donc là on peut
interpréter à son compte comme comme il
suit comme on pousse ses ennemis tous le
pouce aux ventes eu elle ment aux coups
d'état ou à une certaine nervosité est
là on nous dira vous voyez la droite
brésilienne la dictature tout ça donc
c'est de ce sont des temps extrêmement
instable au brésil il n'y a pas beaucoup
de sécurité juridique et politique
c'est vraiment à tempête parfaite corona
crise économique et cet épisode
juridique
merci à vous galy d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste en relations
internationales